Episode 2 of "Loki" left us with a pretty
big cliffhanger - and after Episode 3, we
have even more questions.
The latest episode definitely gave MCU fans
plenty to unpack.
Here's everything about the plot and ending
of "Loki" Episode 3, explained.
Surprisingly, the episode doesn't kick things
off right from the moment Loki and the Variant
step through the Time Door in RoxxCart - instead,
we get the Variant and Hunter C-20, out for
drinks.
The two are drinking margaritas in a supposedly
scummy waterfront restaurant, which is all
an elaborate illusion so the Variant can extract
information about the TVA from C-20.
As we learn towards the episode's end, this
"Inception"-style technique is one of the
Variant's impressive skills that Loki doesn't
seem to have - different Loki, different powers.
With this enchanting skill, it makes the Variant
a pretty formidable opponent, because how
would anyone know what's real if she can make
them believe they're somewhere else just to
get secrets and information out of them?
Anyway, thanks to a sleepy confession from
Hunter C-20, the Variant knows that the elevators
that go to the Time Keepers' chamber are behind
a set of gold doors.
It's still not clear what she'd do if she
came face-to-face with the Space Lizards - the
insinuation is that she'd kill them, but it
seems as if her plans go a little deeper than
that.
Before anything about the Variant's plan can
be revealed, Loki pulls the villain through
another Time Door before Judge Renslayer can
execute them both.
Loki may have saved their lives - but he also
stranded the duo in yet another apocalypse.
Because Loki instinctively took the duo to
a new place in time, he didn't carefully choose
their destination, hurling them onto the doomed
moon of Lamentis-1 in 2077 and draining the
power out of the time-travelling TemPad device
in the process.
While this location isn't a well-known cosmic
setting in the comics or the MCU like Xandar
or Sakaar, the planet Lamentis is featured
in the 2007 "Annihilation Conquest: Prologue"
comics.
Is setting part of "Loki" on Lamentis' moon
a small hint that alien baddie Annihilus is
on the way?
Maybe, but at this point it feels more like
an Easter Egg than a genuine tease for this
longtime Marvel Comics villain.
As Loki and the Variant arrive, the mining
colony and everyone living on the moon is
about to be wiped out by the approaching planet
above it, unless they can escape on a nearby
ship.
After some illusion-trickery, the mischievous
duo sneak their way onto a train heading for
the evacuation craft, the Ark.
With some time to kill, the terrible twosome
chat about their lives and their respective
abilities.
It's arguably the best scene in the episode,
because, like Loki's time-therapy conversations
in the first two episodes, it forces the trickster
to look at his own life from a different perspective.
Meanwhile, audiences probably didn't expect
to hear what the God of Mischief thinks about
love.
We've never seen him in a romantic relationship
in the MCU, but it's clear he's got some very
complicated feelings about love - comparing
it to a dagger, and noting that it can disappear
in an instant.
Loki also reveals that he's bisexual in this
quiet, emotional scene, something later confirmed
by director Kate Herron on Twitter.
Of course, he's already a queer character
within Norse mythology and is gender fluid
in the comics - but it's great that the MCU
has finally acknowledged this.
Though many assumed that the blonde trickster
in "Loki" was Lady Loki, Episode 3 seemed
to reveal that this may not actually be the
case at all.
"Are you sure you're a Loki?"
"You're in my way."
"You are my way!"
She constantly berates our trickster for referring
to her as a Loki, eventually sniping that
her new alias is Sylvie - a detail that was
spoiled in the international credits of Episode
2 a week earlier.
Right about here is where things get complicated.
Sylvie says Loki is "not who [she] is anymore,"
so it seems like the MCU is making her part
Loki, and part another Marvel character: Enchantress.
In the comics, there's a version of Enchantress
amed Sylvie Lushton, who is given Asgardian
abilities by Loki when the Norse gods move
Asgard to Oklahoma.
Marvel Studios has always taken the stories
and details from the comics and put its own
spin on things for the MCU, so it's entirely
possible that Kevin Feige and creator Michael
Waldron have combined Enchantress and Lady
Loki into one variant that honors both characters.
However, Sylvie also starts revealing certain
puzzle pieces about her life before the events
of the series, explaining that she's been
on the run from the TVA for her whole life.
If that's truly the case, then that raises
all sorts of questions about where in Loki's
timeline she may have actually come from - if
she's truly a Loki variant at all.
But that's not all she revealed.
Perhaps the biggest revelation in the episode
comes after the pair of Lokis are thrown off
the train heading to the Ark.
As they traipse across Lamentis, Sylvie explains
that the mind of Hunter C-20 was "messed up"
and "clouded," noting that C-20 had to trawl
through a memory from hundreds of years ago,
from before she joined the TVA.
So far, viewers have been led to believe that
when the Time Keepers created the TVA, they
also created all the agents like Mobius and
Hunter C-20 - but apparently that's not the
truth at all.
Sylvie shockingly reveals that everyone in
the TVA is a variant, just like herself and
Loki.
So does that mean Mobius is obsessed with
jet skis because in his normal timeline he
liked them too?
Which timelines were all the TVA agents from?
How did the Time Keepers assemble them after
the Multiverse War into this cosmic bureaucracy?
And just how does Sylvie know all of this?
In "Loki" Episode 2, the series established
that time-travelers typically don't have any
effect on an apocalypse event because they're
fixed points in time, which means nothing
about it can be changed.
So it does seem a little pointless that Loki
and Sylvie attempt to get on the evacuation
ship in the first place.
Obviously they can't just sit on Lamentis
and wait to die, but it was only last week
that we watched Loki destroy Mobius' salad
to explain just how apocalypse events work.
As such, it was more than just a long shot
that Loki and Sylvie would manage to succeed
here.
The Ark was always destined to blow up, so
it isn't surprising that the episode left
them facing annihilation in the neon-drenched
city.
Sylvie hammers that home when they first land
there, noting that of all the apocalyptic
events they could've gone to, "this is the
worst one."
So, how will Loki get out of this one?
Well, here's a theory: Lamentis-1 might not
be real.
Look at the focus given to Sylvie's enchanting
abilities throughout the episode - what if
she's simply put Loki into an illusion in
an attempt to get more information out of
him about the TVA?
Sure, it would undercut the entire drama and
stakes of this episode, but it would definitely
be an interesting twist.
That said, Sylvie claims the fantasies have
to come from the memories of the person she's
enchanting.
"In order to preserve the connection, I have
to create a fantasy from their memories."
So, by that logic, she couldn't trap Loki
somewhere he's never been, unless this explanation
is also a deception.
At this point, who knows?
Fans will just have to wait to see what happens
to Sylvie and Loki next week - new episodes
of "Loki" drop every Wednesday at midnight,
Pacific Time, on Disney Plus.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Loki are
coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.